on est dans la panade ils arrêtent telle
une star pas une star on a révélé
qu'elle pouvait gagner peut-être plus de
100000 euros sur les réseaux sociaux en
tant qu influence euse moi j'écoute
l'admiration pour cette jeune fille
chocolat quand même réussi quelque chose
d'incroyable à dubaï elle a beaucoup
d'argent
c'est une vraie entrepreneuse bon
maintenant on l'a regardé l'émission
vont vous aider sur elle en disant c'est
pas une star elle se prend pour une star
et cetera elle a regardé l'émission
comme chaque semaine je remercie et du
coup nous a laissé un petit message très
aimable en train de regarder un touche
pas à mon poste people émissions tombent
qui veulent après enfin ils sont grands
mais les choses ces gens parce que genre
ils critiquent tout et pendant toute
l'émission ont critiqué c'est
hallucinant gens aux états unis les gens
qui réussissent entre guillemets sont
revalorisés en france les gens qui
réussissent à un petit peu en effet de
les enterrer et le veer c'est qu'autour
de cette table il y en a pas un qui a
fait ce que j'ai fait il y en a pas un
qui à son entreprise
je les connais même pas pour moi c'est
des moldus je serais même pas mettre des
noms sur ces visages les gars vous ai
rien fait de mal j'aime à magali quibou
laquelle notoire et b
aulas l'a fait qui bouge on sait pas
dans quel sens elle est comme dans la
vraie vie bon c'est pas si avec nous on
a poignardé personnes déjà déjà moi je
la rejoins pardon à la est là elle a
quand même très bien réussi sa vie elle
accueille c'est vrai que ça avec tout ça
prouve quand même que ça marche qu'on
parle de nabila et moi c'est vrai que
malgré tout je suis parfois gaulle avait
calé tout quand je la crois je me dis
oui c'est vrai qu'elle a un truc en plus
cette pique je comprends que votre
visage tu comprends aussi donc on va
parler d'elle mais en tous les cas et
puis un habitat c'est une regarde mais
vraiment vraiment vraiment tu l'as bien
bien bienvenue en cette émission de
cette séance engueuler mais comme tu
sais je crois j'ai beaucoup d'estimé
pour toi et d'ailleurs on parle de toi
dans cette émission et dieu sait qu'on
parle pas de certaines personnes que
j'aime pas à l'eau papier mais qu'elles
passent à neuville à cette choc ce que
tu viens d'entendre
oui parce que elle est en train de dire
que voilà tous les gens autour de cette
table n'ont rien fait contrairement elle
nous ça fait à peu près trente ans qu'on
a on a tous un boulot en affrontant
n'exagère ce qui concerne certaines
personnes on a fait plein de choses mais
elle ne s'est peut-être pas mais on va
voir ce que ça donne sur la longueur
mais pour le moment moi je me demande
c'est quoi son métier donc elle a été
candidate d'une émission de télé réalité
certes mais elle est animatrice sur
instagram pour lui et le vent de l'est
elle est représentée alors là je suis
très énervé alors attendu je suis très
énervé un petit peu de télé on ne parle
pas sur les applaudissent que sinon ne
tentant pas je suis assez énervé parce
que c'est une fille que j'aime plutôt
bien ma fac est ce que senna biladi une
émission qui veulent pas très au pardon
elle a commencé par l'amour est dans le
noir c'est à dire qu'elle s'est fait
repéré parce que l'amour est aveugle
[Applaudissements]
bravo à dax était d'or noir voilà elle
s'est fait repéré parce qu'elle se
foutait à poil dans une émission dans le
noir ok après la fée des anges dont on
met les gens en maillot au bord d'une
piscine pour qu'ils sortent des phrase
débile à la sortie chez plus quoi ilia
ii l'une est ce que c'est quoi voilà
c'est pas elle a été repérée sur les
besoins des banques de la sorbonne 1 au
caire d'accord d'accord
ensuite elle poignard de son mec et
ensuite elle fait d elle est
chroniqueuse de télévision où elle n'est
pas très bonne d'ailleurs à nous elle
n'a pas gardé on est d'accord
après on dit que c'est un artiste passe
est une star une star c'est quelqu'un
qui est légitime et crédible dans le
monde du spectacle
excusez moi elle n'est pas chanteuse
elle n'est pas comédienne elle épate
chroniqueuse de télévision qu'est ce que
c'est nabila non mais qu'est ce que
c'est mais là on en parle chaque semaine
[Applaudissements]
les amis c'est une créature qui marchent
comium de l'ontario jury à nabila alors
et donc voilà la bouche
les amis des amis mais c'est fini oui
c'est un château pour moutier avant 121
rue t&d crème pour les hémorroïdes sur
internet
allez représente mignot energivie procès
alors qu'elle apprenne des militaires
avec arrache guillaume ip guillaume
encore un mot ça va boutin les migrants
un petit peu de calme sur ce plateau
j'aimerais juste préciser quelque chose
ce matin mon ami guillaume que j'aime
beaucoup a voulu prendre une petite
pilule d'oméga 3 je vous raconte est
vrai et malheureusement il est passé
l'une est donc étant totalement aveugle
à son âge il a tâtonné et il a pris je
vous dirai pas la marque parce que c'est
très puissant un somnifère très peu
d'annulations ou depuis le bus c'est ce
qu'a fait il est dans un état pas de
café ouais voilà donc ces propos d'un de
ceux souvent là sont peut-être
incohérences tout va bien il prend un
somnifère puissant à 9h du mat
un petit mot sur des wilayas ce que
j'aime je les aime bien nabila je suis
un peu déçu parce qu'elle dit j'ai
réussi pas les autres et en général
quelqu'un qui dit ça c'est quelqu'un qui
a réussi dans la vie mais qui a pas
réussi sa vie
oui c'est bien le même seul attrait pour
le parc de réussite financière donc
comme dans un style rameurs et savoir
tout bord et ces influenceurs il ne
parle que de fric
il juge la réussite à long ou pas du
tout de faire un enfant elle aime on
voir comme au niveau fric est la plus
réussie que nous probablement pour
l'oreille le nabi là on t'embrasse mais
non mais non en train de parler laden
moi je vais un peu me servir de magali
kevala pour la défense
comment évidemment on parle d'elle on
dit machin bonnel fait rien fait
démonstratrice externe et nour deux oui
c'est une star oui c'est une mort de
stars et c'est pas grave on parle du
staff et les stars ou pas parce qu'elles
paraissent claires à six arénas et
côtoie que vous disiez en attendant en
attendant moi je constate un truc à lui
dans le pays dans lequel elle rêvait
elle vit dans une très grande maison
l on a beau dire des amours de
téléralité elle vit avec le même mec
depuis louis jean sérien d'enfants
salaire beaucoup d'argent elle a créé
une marque plutôt très bien et je crois
qu'elle vous emmerde accord
[Applaudissements]